i think july 1st was the first day of
recession
i think the numbers on gdp has got to
come out july 28th and we'll find out if
it's two quarters of the economy
declining and then it'll become official
with some economists will say that uh
now cnn i don't know if you saw the
article last week by cnn saying
you know
some experts are saying uh uh we're in
recession but why is it that it's eight
white economists that are saying we're
in recession
yeah yeah
yeah when it comes down to recession
nobody cares what color you are
and they said these economists are not
diverse enough you know there's no
african-american economist in america
the african-american population is 13
but only three percent are economists
you know and this percent is this but
that percent is this and i said look you
know in
america
um 24 of the population is hispanic
but in the nba it's only one hispanic
player what a racist organization the
nba is why don't you guys go a little
bit more diverse and have hire some
hispanics there is no iranian basketball
i'm offended that you guys don't have
any iranian basketball players in the
nba so you hear comments like this
people are making to get people
distracted from the fact that
we're in recession
it's what's happening
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the founder and ceo of valuetainment
host of the pbd podcast and author of
your next five moves master the art of
business strategy
patrickbetdavid finally welcome to the
reuben report it's great to be on good
to see you my friend uh we are both
relatively new floridians so i feel we
should start there do you have anything
you want to tell the people about life
in florida
i i got to tell you i lived in la 20
some years minus the time in the
military i lived five years in dallas
texas which was fantastic
i kept one of my companies there
but in florida if california and texas
could make a baby it would be florida
did you get lifestyle and you get the
taxes they kind of leave you alone so
uh we're in love living in florida so
you
moved the company for what was it five
years in dallas and then what caused you
to leave texas because texas is pretty
good you ain't paying the taxes there
it's a nice lifestyle over there was it
purely weather and uh tropical leave
related
yeah that's a good question so for me we
were at a point where we outgrew the
headquarters
and valuetainment and the insurance
company were in the same headquarters
same office
and then it was either i'm gonna sign a
lease of a few years would buy a team in
dallas and kind of move them to a
different building or if i'm moving
that's the time to make the move so at
the time
uh when this decision was being made it
was at the beginning of covid
and my wife and i we were looking at new
york because if we're running a media
company media company you got to be in a
place where you can recruit executives
from the media company you can recruit
talent to want to live there so we said
greenwich new york great it's right
there it's the mecca you can compete the
markets available we looked at tennessee
because the state's taxes
and then we looked at potentially going
back to newport beach california because
you know media again there but covet
happened everything kind of moved away
from there we always go to florida
and then uh i knew
value timid and the media company would
be a lot easier to recruit people to
south florida than any of the other
locations so lifestyle was there i got
four kids now 10 and eight to six
and my daughter just turned one so we
got a family that's a younger startup
family we gotta be in a place that
sports
education all of that combined together
finally we said south florida's place to
go and then obviously the rest is
history and i have seen the video of the
house on youtube and uh it's not bad
let's just say it's not bad
two-bedroom condo you know
very nice place we like it we're very
happy with it yeah two-bedroom condo
might be under the house that you're
rocking over there on the water and
four-letter absolutely beautiful so i
know my audience all knows you from uh
from the business side of things and
mostly from the podcast side of things
and we'll get into some of that stuff
but can you just tell people who don't
know your bio a little bit about growing
up in iran and just some of the some of
the who how you got to where you are
kind of stuff
born and raised in iran lived there in
uh for 10 years in tehran iran during
the revolution with the shah that was
born october 1878
four months later he was in exile they
kicked him out then khomeini showed up
then the military was in shambles
because 2000 of his leaders were
reporting to dusha khamenei got rid of
him saddam saw that as an opportunity he
attacked half a million people got
killed
six weeks after khomeini dies this is
around july 15th of 89 we escape i go to
germany with my mom and my sister we
lived at a refugee camp for a year and a
half and then from germany we came to
the states i went to glendale california
right after high school i joined the
army went to the 101st airborne division
aerosultan and got out of the army i
wanted to be a bodybuilder i was going
to be the next mr olympia you know
arnold schwarzenegger i was gonna
win mr olympia going be an actor mary a
kennedy and then one day run for
governor
but then i met a girl named jean beer
who worked at morgan stanley dean witter
she told me about morgan stanley dean
witter i was 21
and she said this is how i make a living
it's a great industry i started working
on morgan stanley
dean with her a day before 9 11 and then
i stayed in the industry seven and a
half years later i was in transamerica i
was a year at the morgan seven and a
half years transamerica
and then october of nine started my own
insurance company php we grew that from
66 agents to 20 000 plus agents 150
offices nationwide
and then accidentally started a youtube
channel that turned into a media company
valuetainment and then obviously the
rest is history so i love how you say
that all with just such ease i mean i
know you've told that story there's a
million stories within that story i know
you've said it a million times before
but the reason i wanted you to say it
was because you are as much as anyone i
think i've ever had on the show the
living breathing example of what the
american dream is now how could that
possibly be you are a brown-skinned
immigrant i thought that this is the
most racist place i thought we hate
people from the middle east etc etc how
do you do it
you know the power of levity let me give
you an idea what i mean by the power of
levity and the power of
not taking everything personally and
crying about it so i'm in the uh uh in
the army and one time one of these uh uh
soldiers private i'm a boot camp with
these guys and they say so where are you
from i said i'm from iran he says what
do you mean you're from iran i said i'm
from iran so how are you in the military
you know aren't you are you a u.s
citizen i said no i got a green card how
do you get into the military as a you
know iranian
citizen and you're now in our
army i said can you guys keep a secret
they said yeah what's up i said honestly
i'm kind of like an underground spy
operation right now i'm trying to take
all the training from
iran and by the way these guys believed
it and it was to the point where my
sergeant had to come and talk to me
about it and we laughed about it but
obviously there's some levity to it i
remember going to alabama one time and
the waiter at waffle house were on the
way to panama city
florida to party for like a club la
villa
and this panama city waiter is just
looking at me angle and he's like i've
never seen a nose like that before i
said this is what you call
a legit qualified nose from the middle
east you guys don't have stuff like this
in america we have it in iran
i've never met an iranian before i said
i'm an iranian anyways then i go and i
start working on morgan stanley it's a
very interesting story what happens what
time i got into the lds market clients
who were lds and it's a very good market
to get into you know when you're
managing money you're gonna get into
different kind of markets car wash
owners doctors one of the markets i got
into was lds and there's one business
owner i sat with i go into their house
it's right after 9 11.
and they said can you tell us about your
background i said sure born and raised
in iran out of all this stuff and i said
nana morgan standing managing money and
you know helping our families and she
says look we don't mind doing business
with anybody from morgan stanley but we
would like you to be somebody else with
a background that we can relate to quite
frankly after what happened with the 911
we feel a little bit uncomfortable doing
business with somebody from the middle
east
now in that situation i can say
how dare you say that and go cry and
complain about it i said totally
understand
left brought back my partner they met
they did business we split commission we
were happy with god moral the story is
i don't care who you are if you're a
white black asian middle eastern tall
short fat skinny educated not educated
you got a beard you don't have a beard
you have a mustache you don't have a
mustache everyone's getting judged
whether you like it or not and the
reason why this is a topic i'm bringing
up is because
as much as everyone's judging us we're
also judging people so if you get to
judge others why can't they judge you
and i so
the challenge is how we react to it you
can go and think like you're a victim i
cannot believe what he said or you can
go prove them wrong maybe that person
was right maybe they didn't make the
right decision and then maybe 20 years
later they're sending their husband and
wife and saying babe
that was the guy that we said no to and
look at him now look how successful he
is but either way someone's gonna be
right
so when you're saying the whole american
dream success story look i'll tell you
something about right now
the time we're in right now
there is two camps
there's the camps
that are like well listen don't worry
it's just not a big deal it's going to
be a small market correction you know
like the dave ramsey camp real estate's
not going to really take because look at
the inventory it's not really that high
maybe dave ramsey's right maybe he's not
but it's going to be all right don't
worry about it and then there's a camp
that's going to be like listen
i think it's a [ __ ] show i think i
better pay attention to what's going on
what do you mean you know inventory is
going up interest rates are going up
inflation is going up gas prices are
going up fourth of july cost me 11 more
this year than they did last year making
a million dollars two years ago and you
make it today it's like making six
hundred thousand dollars today just two
years later a hundred thousand dollars
two years ago sixty thousand dollars but
at the same time that can either produce
a lot of fear for you
and you don't moving you don't do
anything or you can look at this
marketplace where fear is high you just
have to know the american dream of the
next great stories are burned you know
born during times of crisis
the american dream is alive anybody and
everybody can go out and have their
dreams become a reality whatever that
may be but it will take a lot of effort
and you not taking things personally
so that what you just said there i think
has been your main message that i've
been picking up on for the last two
months as as the economy's gotten real
weird and so much craziness with this
administration everything that more than
anything else there's opportunity here
right now is that something that you
always saw did your parents teach you
that is that just from the immigrant
story like where did that idea of oh
things are kind of crappy but i have a
chance within that where'd that come
from right so my parents you know you
got my mom
they their their bible was the communist
manifesto i come from a very strong
communistic family from my mother's side
who escaped russia baku azerbaijan and
they went to uh bandar pahlavi which is
like a port palabi north of tehran and
they stayed there but their bible was
communist manifesto you know admiring
stalin and lenin and you know how they
led and so my mother's side she thought
rich people were greedy and my dad said
he was an imperialist
he thought poor people were lazy so i'm
completely confused in the middle of
here
i remember i was uh
14 years old i'm in high school
and uh we start talking about politics
first time in my life where you know
actually you want to know what's a
democrat and a republican because we
didn't talk about that stuff early on
because my parents got two divorces in
20 years over politics i come home one
day and i'm like hey mom
are we democrats or are we republicans
and she said we're democrats it's okay
cool i said can you tell me why we're
democrats she says yeah because
democrats are for the poor and
republicans are for the rich
i said mom when i grow up i want to be a
republican one day
she's like what do you mean i want to be
rich one day i hate being broke i want
to do something about my life that i
have going on but you know in regards to
fear my dad worked at a 99 cent store
his entire life
my dad was worried so he wanted me to
stay in the military for 20 years and
that was the safe route my dad's always
been the very safe guy who worked 80
hours a week always been a worker my
mother was very paranoid who just didn't
want me to become rich and
successful because those are the people
she despised the most but when i got out
of the military i had a mentor of mine
robbie who recommended me a book called
how to master the art of selling by tom
hopkins i'm working at bally total
fitness and my sister recommended me how
to win friends and influence people by
bill carnegie i read those books dave
and i got to tell you 2 000 books later
i could not believe all this information
is in these 10 books 8 books 15 books i
got obsessed the stuff i learned from
there i applied to my business
and then obviously the rest is it is
what it is today
do you consider yourself political
because it's kind of funny when i listen
to you it's like you're the way you talk
about politics is sort of seemingly an
extension of the way you talk about
business and money like you don't strike
me as
purely political i mean that as a
compliment actually like you have a lot
of political insight but to me it's
usually connected back to what you're
talking about on a business side of
things
i would say i am pro-capitalist
and extremely aware of everything that's
going on around me because if you're not
you know
we become naive and oblivious to the
conditions and sometimes you vote
thinking it's the right choice and then
two years later you realize 85 percent
of americans are not happy about the
economy yet 81 million people voted for
this
two years ago and a lot of them that
voted they would like their vote back
and it's not because of its you know who
joe biden is i'm sure he's a great
father and a husband that's none of my
business that's his personal life i
don't care how he's running his marriage
that's none of my business i didn't care
what trump did with his personal life
and all this stuff that you saw with you
know bush in the rv and grabbing this
that stuff is to you you want to party
that way all to you i want to see what
kind of policies you're making so
when when you do your taxes the first
time when you make real money and you
cut the biggest check you've ever cut
and i was in my mid to late 20s i'm
sitting there saying okay
where is this money going to
and you're sitting there saying well
this is this goes to taxes no i get that
but
where is this actually going to like
what are you gonna do with this hundred
thousand dollars you got this year what
are we gonna do is that gonna be the
road is that the exit sign is that the
building is that the public's where's it
going and what portion of that am i
using and what portion am i getting that
i'll never use
and is it a responsible way they're
spending this money so then you start
asking yourself
would we be better putting that money in
the
in taxes and allowing government
employees
to do better with that money or is that
money better being put into the private
market
of those who know how to do good things
with that money that'll benefit
everybody better and then you start
saying
what is this all about so then that kind
of gets you to the next level in the
next level so for me it started with
business then i noticed how policies can
affect your business regulation taxes
all that stuff then it went deeper
deeper even i said no you got to pay
attention to all the stuff that's going
on were you shocked after 20 plus years
in la then you go to texas where there's
no income tax now you're in florida
where there's no income tax i mean to me
i don't want to say this out loud
because i don't want to give him any
ideas but it's like i would have paid an
entry tax to get here i truly would have
if they would have said dave you got to
pay 50 grand to get into this state
because we've done it right and we're
trying to keep you freaks from cali out
of here i would have done it i think
it's actually probably a worthy thing to
look into when you're bringing in all of
these new people but the fact the simple
fact is i didn't move here for taxes but
now i'm like wow i also have all more
money than i had even if the money isn't
worth as much as it used to used to be
yeah i mean listen what what people
sometimes when you're in a bad
relationship you don't know
until you have another relationship oh
my god what was that all about this is
like you know unbelievable like 180. but
sometimes you need to be in a bad
relationship to know and value a great
relationship
sometimes you need a bad friend to
realize what a great friend is sometimes
you need a crisis to know what life is
like when you're at peace sometimes you
need to go through a dark time to be
reminded of what it's like when there's
light living in california right now
look here's how it works if i was
governor desantis and you've had many
many interactions with them uh if if i
was governor desantis and somebody said
well i don't like what you're doing with
this i don't like what you're doing with
that i don't like what you're doing i
don't like these you know
masks and you know there's this stuff
you're doing with
don't say you know gay bill and stuff
your disney and the stuff you know with
taxes and just i don't like the way you
handle vaccine all this stuff i would
say look
if these seven things are important if
you like high taxes
if you want somebody to make decisions
for you if you want all of this stuff i
will buy a one-way ticket for you to
move to california
i'd be pushing people out of florida
who don't like the policies
that's being built at the same time
i would also say if you're watching this
and you like the following five things
this is what we do in florida this is
the perfect home for you so like right
now desantis came out and called him out
yesterday or you you saw that over the
weekend uh newsom's trying to call out
the same oh yeah wow let me tell you in
florida if you stand up in florida you
should stand up for yourself i believe
in freedom of this and freedom to be
heard and freedom to be nothing no you
don't
no you don't you don't believe that
stuff you don't believe that stuff so a
desantis in florida you don't like what
we do in florida go to california i i
think more states
because if you think about the one state
that doesn't matter when it comes on to
elections what is the one state
definitely doesn't matter when it comes
on to elections california yeah okay so
guess what send everybody who wants high
taxes to california
send everybody who wants entitlements to
california if you love it so much here's
a one-way ticket go to california and
then everybody else everybody else that
wants the job creators like you and i
come on down here yeah and not only that
but you can have your eight-month
abortions and you can have your uh
genitals chopped off or added or
whatever it might be it's a it's a
bizarre a bizarre situation so you move
these companies and you bring your
you're all the people that are working
for you what about just sort of
spiritually for everybody because i know
for my guys just every everybody's life
is better than putting aside finances
that it's not just about that just the
quality of life
so spiritually you're saying what do you
mean by spiritually just the day-to-day
when you're seeing these people and how
their their lives improved by by moving
into a place yeah yeah oh i mean listen
when i was moving to texas uh we it took
us three years i was selling texas for
three years before we moved to texas my
wife is from texas she was born and
raised in houston lived there for 21
years and she did not want to go to
texas so i sold texas texas texas every
time an article would come out about
texas i would sell it
until eventually we moved and i knew you
know a few things that goes as family
you're going to miss family you're going
to miss knowing the freeways you're
going to miss the church you go to
you're going to miss the starbucks you
go to you're going to miss the gym you
go to and the quick routine that you
follow all of these routines you miss
what you do on sundays all those things
and then eventually
three six months later people in texas
are like
i don't miss any of that stuff in
california and if i need to take a
flight i'll just get on a flight go to
california for a weekend and i'll come
back on a flight it's easy to go then
you come to florida
and you start seeing what you're able to
do here in florida with the lifestyle
with the different things that it offers
and okay what are the downfalls of
florida uh iguanas there's there's going
to be iguanas here okay if you live in
orlando and you live by like a little
pond there's probably an alligator in
there okay if you live by the water like
where you live or where i live you're
probably not dealing with uh you know uh
alligators or crocodiles that you're
gonna be there if you're on the inside
sure
are you gonna get weather storms yes
every state has something that you're
not gonna be happy with california is
gonna be earthquake texas is gonna be
tornadoes you know blizzards florida's
going to be storm or hurricanes no
matter where you're going to have that
but on a golf score
if you mark it on 20 different things
good luck trying to beat florida
you know it's funny in california it was
like raining fire half the year and then
i moved here and people said but it's so
hot in the summer and i'm like it was
literally raining fire there were ashes
being dumped on my house every other
week all right so let's let's move on to
some of the some of your sort of nuts
and bolts stuff because we talked a
little bit about economy a couple weeks
ago you had a video out that i saw where
i think you said but correct me if i'm
wrong that you said that we would
officially or they would officially
announce a recession i think you said by
july 15th
it seems to me they've already kind of
admitted it yellen has sort of you
probably saw the video where she said
well we're probably in one but we're
hopeful and then they all kind of admit
it well i i guess a do you think we are
i mean i think technically we are in a
recession but do you think they will
admit it and how do you feel about july
15th middle of the month i mean are we
there
i think july 1st was the first day of
recession
i think the numbers on gdp has got to
come out july 28th and we'll find out if
it's two quarters of the economy
declining and then it'll become official
with some economists will say that
now cnn i don't know if you saw the
article last week by cnn saying you know
some experts are saying uh uh we're in
recession but why is it that it's eight
white economists that are saying we're
in recession
yeah yeah
yeah when it comes down to recession
nobody cares what color you are
and they said these economists are not
diverse enough you know there's no
african-american economist in america
the african-american population is 13
but only three percent are economists
you know and this percent is this but
that percent is this and i said look you
know in
america
um 24 of the population is hispanic
but in the nba it's only one hispanic
player what a racist organization the
nba is why don't you guys go a little
bit more diverse and have hire some
hispanics there is no iranian basketball
i'm offended that you guys don't have
any iranian basketball players in the
nba so you hear comments like this
people are making to get people
distracted from the fact that we're in
recession
it's what's happening now the question
becomes
how ugly can it get
and you know how many people will be
prepared for and what policies the
current administration will come my
hopes is they don't do one thing and the
one thing i hope they don't do because
it's going to happen when lehman
brothers when aig when all these
companies are going through what they
went through on 07.0809 when we remember
what happened there
those stories are going to come up when
some banks are not going to make it
you're going to hear some stories of
some of these companies that are
auto companies they're not going to make
it and they're going to need to be
bailed out i just hope dave they don't
go the bailout model because if they go
to bailout model what the bailout model
does is it just delays the headache for
10 more years it delays the headache for
10 more years it keeps delaying it
versus let's just go through it and
here's what's going to happen with the
economy if we go through it so
interest rates right now 5.7
which means you would have bought a
house eight months ago your rates would
have been three percent two and a half
percent right now it's 5.7
here's what people don't realize
if you go back from today
let's just say go all the way back to
1970.
do you know from 2008
prior from 2008 and prior like 1970 to
2008 do you know the interest rates have
never been at 5.7 percent it's always
about 5.7
let me say this one more time from 08
and prior to 70 rates have always been
six and a half seven and a half eight
and a half nine and a half
in 81 under carter was at 18 and a half
percent okay but that was pretty bad now
let's go worst case scenario let's go
best case scenario and you decide where
you want to manage your level of risk
tolerance worst case scenario we're
going to hit 19 in interest rates what's
the likelihood of that happening less
than 5
okay
but that's 19 that's worst case what's
the best case scenario we end up around
seven seven and a half and we stayed
there for a few years okay we go to
seven seven and a half maybe we go up
and hit ten points which we probably
will and then we come back down and
level off around seven to eight percent
which is fine if we stay at seven to
eight percent for a decade give or take
a decade and we're kind of like i got a
good rate what rate did you get 7.1
percent fine
but now we're going back to being
fiscally responsible instead of keeping
these interest rates at zero and you're
getting loans at two and a half percent
which is all fake money and it's not the
real way of doing it so yes we're in
recession but
i'm almost
i'm almost leaning towards the
administration doing nothing now the
only thing i would recommend if the
administration wanted to do something
like this
who who does the current administration
need the most today well
um a story came out talking about the
fact that companies now are rescinding
offers how often do you even read an
article like that that means
twitter gave you a job offer for a
hundred grand with fifty thousand
dollars in bonuses with 401k all the
stuff
you get started on the 19th
and they say to you a week later after
you put in your two week notice we're
rescinding that job
okay
zuckerberg is wanting to fire people
he's doing the right thing tesla's
firing people a bunch of companies are
letting people go and that's gonna be
taking place now
if that happens and a lot of people lose
their jobs economy is going to take a
hit
crime's going to go up a lot of scary
things could happen if economy that's
that gap gets that bad the one thing
biden and their administration could
potentially do is
and dave you tell me what you think
about this what if they said
hey
you got these five employees you could
hire this year at 50 grand or pop let's
just pick the number 50 or pop five
times 50 if you hire five employees you
give them a job mr employer mr small
business owner which is 49 of america 49
of all the jobs are small business
owners
um if you give those five people 50 000
your jobs will give you tax credit on
half of it which means what i mean
because i hire five people overnight
that's what i would do yeah so now small
business owners are like listen john
come on 50k 25 000 tax credit come on so
that way
the employer wins the employee wins and
the administration wins those are the
types of things that the administration
can do not the ppp loan not free money
not at ubi no let's kind of work
put it on me put it on the employee put
it on the government let's work together
the next two three years because it's
gonna get ugly so i can hear loudly
through the pipes of the internet all of
the people watching this going patrick
you just made sense there but the
problem is that the democrats are in
charge and that there is basically a
controlled demolition of our economy one
of the things that i talk about on the
show a lot is i try not to judge
people's motives but it seems almost
impossible for me to believe that this
is not intentional that the inflation
stuff is not intentional the printing of
money is not intentional all the peop
everything that they have done has been
designed specific everything with energy
specifically designed to destroy the
economy so of course what you just said
there makes sense like anything
literally anything some tax relief for
people fine but they won't do any of it
because it is by design do you do you
buy that theory
oh let's play let's play that card let's
buy this
i hope it is great do it by design do it
but i'm totally okay with you doing it
by design here's why
because
they think majority of the american
people are dummies and they're not
let's not let's not expect that
everybody's brilliant no we're naive if
we think that
let's let's say 40 of people are not
going to pay attention to anything and
they're going to fall for that you're
right it's the rich man's fault let's
tax the billionaires it's not going to
solve anything right but if that's their
card it'll backfire why let's unpack
that
so go with
defund the police what a great marketing
campaign
and the republicans were so worried look
at these i can't believe they're saying
this let them say it
because their own people are going to
turn against them six months later the
hell are you talking about defunder
police democrats are saying it to
democrats i voted for you i don't want
you to defund the police
well we never said it it was really the
republicans no no you said it you said
this this is not a good idea so watch
this this whole concept where you know
many people on the left were saying you
companies corporations you should let
people work from home or really yes
you should let people work from home no
problem who said that
liberal governors from left-leaning
states okay
they said that sounded like a very good
idea like you're supporting so many
people on your own site no no here's
what you did when you said you should be
able to let them work from home the
people said oh so you need to tell me i
can work for ibm and work from home yes
no problem new york i'm moving to
florida and i'll work from
new york lost
21 billion dollars of tax revenue last
year so even though dave they're doing
it intentionally if they are
majority of america is going to fall for
the tactic tactics and they're going to
say yeah i'm kind of not with you i'm
stepping away from you and they'll flip
how do you think the blue states get out
of it i mean i know we could sit here
all day talking about how great florida
is and i think people get that but for
the states like new york so you lose 21
billion california lost around 300 000
people i think it's even more than that
at this point all the tax money that
comes with that and it's not just that
it's the type of people that leave it's
people that are good community members
that care that are honest that work hard
those are the people that are fleeing um
what do you think happens to the blue
states like is there a bottom to that
hole basically is there a rock bottom
there or is it just a free fall now
so so you see the people like yourself
dave how many states you think would
love to have you every state would love
to have you think about how many
countries would left
love to have us think about it let's go
live in you know pick a country canada
let's go live in panama 2.3 unemployment
low unemployment three percent on them
let's go live in france let's go
anywhere we're gonna bring value to
wherever we move to the problem with the
blue states people is the following
they're forcing people like you and i
out
the challenge that happens when you push
people like us out
you may be only left with people that
were relying on the people that were
creating the economy argentina right now
i think some 11 million people work
to take care of the 8 million people
that are not working that system doesn't
work okay what do people eventually do
they eventually leave now watch what
happened in colombia with the new guy
they brought in
do people realize who this guy was
before yeah
what philosophies does he bring in same
thing that venezuela did with maduro
same thing that cuba did colombia is
going to be next venezuela and cuba
that's taking place right now so
unfortunately
certain decisions that is made policies
have consequences and they've some of
them longer than others detroit was the
richest city per capita in the world
in
the world like
rich people would go to detroit to go to
parties like if you lived in detroit you
like i'm living in dearborn oh my god as
a rich kid have you been to detroit
lately have you seen what's going on
well a couple of years ago and it is a i
mean it looks like a third world country
you go into those suburbs with those
houses it looks like bombings
yeah yeah so some of these bad policies
i think it's
it's such negative effects on the
economy of that state that it may take
decades and decades to recover
unfortunately
but i mean do you think they have any
chance like what would be the turnaround
is it just that they have to then okay
let's basically vote republican get some
sane person here like what is the
mechanism that would exist to turn it
around so i'm a data guy i love hiring
analysts so for example we can hire a
gun problem with 50 analysts in a room
and if i can work with the fbi and the
government to get all the data we can
figure out what's the main marker that
caused the most mass shooting and
instead of trying to ban this and we're
spending so much time with this just go
watch the movie money ball
and
billy bean and
and we'll realize you thought home runs
were important no one cares home runs is
not how you go to the top on base
percentage we can get data so let's go
to the states so if we want to find out
a guy to win in california let's use
that as a case study because you know we
are very we have an affinity california
okay so put the 20 policies down to win
in california guns second amendment okay
lgbtq
uh taxes uh health insurance uh i don't
know just put all those policies down
and in which one of the policies
is
economy driven which one of them is
social where a straight up larry elders
are not going to win in california today
right where you need a bit of a hybrid
guy not an arnold who was eventually
fully became pretty much a rhino he was
not necessarily a republican he won
flipped on the other side so you get
somebody like that that maybe a shamath
or maybe some of these guys that are
willing to stay fiscally on the right if
if they can find a candidate like almost
like a peter thiel okay
a guy like a peter thiel who made six
billion dollars off his roth ira because
he understands laws and tax code you
bring the guy like they're not going to
get peter thiel by the way i know it's
this thing like a guy like him he'll
never do it but and i don't think i
don't think they're going to get him on
the roth i.r.a thing either he's not
going to run for governor that's for
sure but i don't think they're going to
get him on that either but if california
understood what they had with peter
thiel like are you do you realize who p
who you lost with p everybody worries
about who they lost you lost peter thiel
you could have had peter thiel to help
your state out like how do you not use
the talent pool that you have in your
state so but if they got a guy like
peter thiel
smart understands economy
so he is socially he can be you know
sitting there saying i can work here i
can work here i can work there but if
you if you throw those data points out
you'll be able to figure out who can run
for that and you've got to find somebody
that matches those six points that they
can sell to that state because
california is a little bit more
complicated than others say to find a
real candidate that has a chance of
winning
so let's talk about your book for a
second so your next five moves uh you've
sort of well you've been kind of hitting
on all the moves in a way here uh in the
time that we've been talking um what's
kind of next for you like what what are
some of the next moves you're looking at
right now
so uh
this is going live okay so i i just had
a massive exit that i went through a uh
a very nice exit that we just have
congratulations great partnership thank
you
and for us we're very excited about the
insurance company it's grown from where
it was at 66 agents to today uh what we
built that's an exciting thing that
we're going through in the process we're
very very excited about it but for me
i look at it right now with the
marketplace and media i think the next
20 years i believe in 20-year runs i got
two more 20-year runs god willing the
next 20-year run is going to be purely
on the media side uh the messaging of
capitalism is what we're gonna be
leading with when it comes down to
business i think that part of the
message with capitalism is it's not fox
news right it's not cnn left it's
people on the left right middle any any
any angle you look at everybody wants to
figure out a way how to get better in
business you can be a democrat and still
be a capitalist you can be a republican
and still be a capitalist so our vision
is to tell the story of capitalism with
the best stories that we can find
whether it's through movies
documentaries shows our own ott uh our
original series that we produce
ourselves comedy we're recruiting a lot
of comedians right now we're recruiting
a lot of podcasters right now that will
bring in here a close friend of yours
jedidiah bila just got stuck with us she
moved here from new york and we're
looking for many more uh we i'm
currently in one of the buildings i just
bought you came to this building we did
the podcast it was in a bank called we
have another building that we own that
we're going to create a live show where
you know you can do your live podcast
with 200 people sitting in front of you
and security sheriff there protection
safety and you're talking to your guests
let's just say you're doing something
with whoever your guest is 200 people
are sitting there they're buying tickets
to come here so
we're taking a complete different angle
of where we're going next but i think
the next 20 years media is wide open you
just saw msnbc is moving away from
rachel maddow you just saw cnn plus
spent 300 million dollars and all they
could get is 10 000 active listeners
they took a wallace away from fox and
they shut the deal down and they spent
three not a sped let me say the ward
better they wasted 300 million dollars
america's sitting there saying where do
i get my news from today everyone's
curious you're seeing a great job daily
wire ben shapiro on their campus doing
you're seeing a complete different angle
like barstool sports is going and
they're entertaining there's so many
different ways of doing it but i think
the opportunity is wide open for the
media side and that's what we plan on
doing next 20 years patrick you'll love
this speaking of the 300 million that
cnn pissed away on that thing you know
how much money i have spent in the
history of my show the history of the
reuben report on advertising guess how
much
how much
well i'm uh we're in this i've never
spent a dime yeah but here but here's
the thing though here's the thing though
so
that that validates that your voice
there's millions on top of millions not
even millions there's tens of millions
of people
that want to hear from you okay
there's a market that if your message is
sincere if you're straight up
if you're willing to talk and call out
your own side any sites and you're
you're receptive to whatever feedback
they're going to give you you're willing
to evolve just like all of us are
evolving some of our opinions are
changing you went from an organization
you were a part of before where it was
seen like being in one place and you
have a meeting with larry elder and then
boom you're like oh my god this kind of
makes sense the fact that you're shown
being open-minded that is that's
inspiring other people to say
well if dave can set aside his ego and
he can be man what the hell am i i keep
getting in my own way so your level of
you know people relate to your
authenticity and they're attracted to it
and they it's very
very hard to find authentic voices like
yours so i am not surprised you're
kicking ass without having to spend a
single penny well likewise my friend and
that actually gets me back to something
that you hit a few minutes ago sort of
this idea of selling capitalism so in my
last book i wrote a chapter on be a
capitalist in essence and when i was
writing it i had a researcher that was
helping me and we were diving into it
and i was like man
some of this basic stuff about
capitalism about why the free market
works about what it does for you sort of
spiritually and and that you have some
autonomy over your life etc
is it ironic to you that the capitalists
have not sold capitalism well that it
seems like a sell job on capitalism that
was the failure it wasn't the system it
was the marketing i guess well listen
look look everything is in the way you
tell stories think about how
pro-abortion didn't work who who wants
to pro abort
pro-choice you change the word same
exact thing look what happens to it
there's nothing more powerful than
pro-life
i'm pro-life what a great
you know name phrase pro-life right so
market make america great again it's a
pro-life message i'm with her i don't
understand that but dream obama wow that
that wording is like dream you know
obama's going to do something this is
exciting so you know in real estate many
years ago
uh you know when you think about an
america what is the american dream if
you ask the average person right now we
do like a street team you and i go to
new york i go to boston and we meet up
later on tonight you go ask people on
streets of new york you guys i go as
people on streets of boston what is the
american dream they'll say home
ownership
who told you some ownership well it's a
marketing genius years ago when they
noticed more people are renting than
buying and they said wait a minute guys
we got to make money people don't start
to realize it doesn't make any sense to
buy a house rent like today it doesn't
make any sense to buy a house right now
it's better to turn to rent and buy a
house what do we do we got to figure
something out this marketing genius said
look why do immigrants come to america
they come to america for the american
dream what if we're able to convince all
of america that the american dream
starts with home ownership how do we do
that i don't care what company you're a
part of in this topic we all got to be
on the same page everybody that spends
every advertising dollar when it comes
down to american dream we all do it the
same way what do you mean here's how the
commercial should sound like
hey you know
i'd love one day for us to live the
american dream what are you talking
about how much longer do we need to rent
we came to america so we can own our own
home that's the american dream and you
see the commercial they open the keys in
the door they go inside
wife kisses the husband and say oh my
god it feels so amazing living the
american dream boom
everybody bought a house why it's the
flipping american dream
capitalists
suck
at telling the story of capitalism and
do you know why i'll tell you why a big
part of it
have you noticed that jeff bezos has
grass grown some brass lately i don't
know if you've noticed that yeah well he
seems like he's doing a little bit of a
shift although he's still doing some
evil stuff with washington post but i'll
give him a little something okay
why do you think though why do you think
let's actually unpack that why why is he
talking what are you doing twice in
three months you call out biting on
twitter what are you doing you voted for
this guy so why is he doing that there's
only one way i can speculate
who's the guy
that gets more attention than he does
who gets more attention than he does
that's as rich as he is
well elon yeah i'm here to tell you my
speculation
elon musk is indirectly training bezos
to grow some
and bezos starting to finally realize
i'm a freaking badass
what the hell am i doing being so afraid
of walking on eggshells around everybody
i'm one of the richest guys in the world
if i'm not the richest so capitalists
are afraid for others to know they're
successful first of all screw the people
that are bashing you for you being
successful there's the other 50 percent
of america that has wanted to listen to
the american dream stories because they
also want to live their dream so inspire
them don't lose your back don't go tell
the story of how you did it go tell them
how hard it was go tell them to
sleepless nights go tell them the amount
of time you slept under your office desk
you your pillow was the floor you're
like just sitting there getting up
coding in the morning tell those stories
because people want to know that and
then eventually
more people are going to sit there and
say
man what the hell am i like why do i
bash so many rich people dude i wanna i
wanna go i'm sick and tired of being
broke i wanna make some money so i think
capitalists have to stop apologizing for
being successful and just tell them the
way you did it and be okay that you're
gonna get hate you're supposed to get a
you're a winner winners get all the hate
stop like being confused that
everybody's supposed to like you when
you win people don't like a winner like
um michael jordan was a hate most hated
player when he was winning all the time
lebron was hated kobe would say that
steph curry's currently hated draymond
greenish hate it but we love winners we
admire them so i think sometimes
capitalists have lost their backbone i'm
glad to see i'm not a wacko fan but i'm
glad to see that even the bezos is
willing to kind of grow some and say hey
and maybe it's the girl that's doing it
to him that's saying listen you're bad i
say something
you gotta say something you're pretty
big bad at say something so i'm kind of
feeling like we're seeing the transition
i may be wrong but i'm seeing that
transition which is good news well for
the record i think lebron with the
flopping and the china stuff maybe is
deserving kobe not so much jordan not so
much they they killed everybody uh but
it's interesting that you said the thing
about elan because i think you're right
he's mapping something that's one of the
things i've been saying on the show for
months now maybe he's mapping it for
bezos but i think he's mapping it for
everybody because even if he's the
world's richest man he's still just one
guy and he's saying hey i will not bow
because you hear this all the time well
you know i'm going to say what i want
when i've got fu money and i'm sure
patrick you probably know way more of
the of the you know billionaire class
than i do they often don't teal does
he's one of the guys that will do the fu
to everybody but i think what happens is
they start going oh now i have all these
employees i have all these houses i have
all these responsibilities so they
become more
quiet than they were before and elon i
think is now mapping hey get out there
and do something although i will say as
we're recording this right now he's gone
quiet on twitter for a little bit i'm
not exactly sure what's going on there
so something something weird might be
brewing
it may be the closing of the deal then
he is told by the lawyers on the other
side that you have to stay quiet until
the deal closes
and you know i went through the process
myself on a much much smaller deal but
it's still a multi multi multi nine
figure deal and you're told by lawyers
to stay quiet so that could be some of
the things that's being find you know uh
uh scored away like kind of putting it
together that both lawyers are saying
you can't say anything on twitter
so
the mapping though this general idea of
like do something for yourself that
that's sort of it more than anything
else doesn't matter if you're rich or
poor
yeah you know you know what's the best
thing about that
it's the first person that does it makes
it okay for the other guys to do it so
elon is mapping it out for bazels and
others to say here
you can be super successful
you can say what you want to say in
twitter and you can piss people off and
that's okay it's supposed to be that way
stop being so soft worried about what
others are gonna say about you i got a
lot of employees and some of them don't
agree with me politically but you know
what happened i'll stop and i said tell
me how you feel that why you feel that
way well patrick the other day on the
podcast you said xyz i disagree with you
really tell me why
okay that's a good point okay fair
enough i can this is why i said this i
never thought about that before well why
don't we keep continuing this
conversation see where it goes six
months from now fair enough so that's
what's going to happen if your employees
are against you or they don't agree what
you have what you have to say but the
opposite of you standing there and not
saying anything and not taking a stand
well then that's typically not the
qualities of a leader we admire bezos
and musk
have the same amount of net worth
bezos and musk don't have the same
amount of influence and following
elon has 100 million people following
him on twitter bezos got 5 million
that's 20 times more the influence same
amount of wealth
people are starting to realize you can
be as rich as you want but you don't
have a voice and elon's teaching you you
need a voice today grab the mic and
start increasing your influence
hopefully can you imagine if all of a
sudden bezos comes out and says the
following like think about imagine bezos
says this when elon said honestly moving
forward i can't see myself voting for
the left i just can't if a desantis ran
i would i would vote for him musk said
it they rogan says it imagine a baseball
do you re bill morris coming out saying
some stuff about do you realize how
scary this is for the left
this is a nightmare for them so this is
why i say to you as much as if you think
they're doing it intentionally good
because it's not working yeah for the
record this is michael malus who i've
had on the show many times do you know
michael malus have you ever i do i had
him on once oh you've had him yeah
this is his running theory for years has
been every time the left says something
crazy you just tell people about it and
more and they'll just keep running with
the craziness so since you just
mentioned desantis and since we are both
proud floridians uh let's map something
out in real time and maybe it'll get to
the governor or to uh donald trump what
do you think is going to happen with
these two what what do you want to
happen because i've been kind of like
you know i want desantis to stay here
crush it in the next election his
gubernatorial election obviously in
november
and then see what happens but it seems
like trump's gonna run i don't want them
to destroy each other it's like do you
if you if you were sitting in a room
with the two of them what would you be
telling them right now okay so so first
of all i don't think it's a good idea if
they run
uh simultaneously i don't think it is i
think i would like to broker a deal
of them to having a dinner together that
nobody knows about including either one
of their administration except for like
the main
mastermind like you know the main uh
influencers there so and that's only two
voices and they set up a meeting
and they go and sit down and talk
privately for a couple hours then maybe
the couple the advisors are sitting
there and they say so look here's what i
want to do here's what i want to do
what's the plan let me ask you a
question would you be willing to be a vp
um
no
okay
so then are you okay not running this
year his advisor may say
he's so hot he has to run if he doesn't
run he's missing out on a great
opportunity he's young he's attractive
america is tired of seven year old
president
and maybe america wants to have a 43 44
45 year old president
and he's pekin
and sometimes in situations like this
you can't assume you're always going to
you're always going to pee life doesn't
work
five years from now the policies may not
matter a lot and he's irrelevant maybe
not irrelevant but not at the level that
he has so we think he's going to be
running okay so if he runs then what are
we doing are you going to call me out
are we going to bash each other how are
we going to win this thing here how are
we going to talk to the media that's
number one step for me it's brokering a
sit-down dinner with the two of them
that nobody is aware of except from two
parties on each side now
let's say that uh doesn't happen okay
all right so you heard the five days ago
trump said i would entertain the idea of
him running with me as a vp that's a
little bit of a dig because if i'm
desantis and i see this i'm like what
are you talking about running with you
as a vp i i could win if i wanted to run
right now now trump may say you don't
have a 141 and 11 record
i 141 and 11. my endorsements out of the
150 something things you know
endorsements i've given 141 i have a
better record than the 97 98 bulls is
what i get you want to go against that
so and then he said if they run together
this will be the last one dave is
if you're putting the basketball team
together
it makes no sense to have shaq and
nikima on the same team because you got
two fives there's two centers
it makes no sense for kobe and jordan to
be teammates they make zero sense look
how many of these super teams they team
up and they don't win championships
boston celtics which they don't really
tatum is a superstar but not like a
crazy and they go to the finals and they
play against
golden state because those are actual
teams like it's shown to you teams are
winning last year was milwaukee and sons
teams are winning right
so i don't know if i like the
trump and desantis ticket and i don't
even believe desantis even believes when
trump says i would pick him as a vp
because i think the last minute trump
would flip and he would take somebody
else and would leave him out as a vp
i don't think he would take him as a vp
because because trump trump is going to
do better trump is looking more for a
ceo
he's not looking for ceo mike pence was
a ceo
santis is a ceo so two ceos as a
president vp i don't that's a good
formula yeah it's so interesting well
first off i have to say i'm very happy
to hear that clearly you are watching
the reuben report every single day
because i've been pushing for the
private sit down that's been my thing
guys just have a private sit down i
don't know what you're gonna work out
but you guys have to work it out and it
doesn't have to be worked out in front
of all of us that's been my my main
thing you know what i would love to see
is you know if trump could sort of be
the king maker here if he could you know
clear the room for desantis to run right
through i think that probably is the
best you know run the rallies and make
some room but yes your face right there
is what everyone kind of says it's like
can he do that would he do that
i don't know what you know would be a
crazy thing here's what's a crazy thing
if trump
um
hey this will never happen but if a
trump was able to have the meeting
and the vp candidate becomes his
daughter
so they were to say well why don't you
go well my daughter's going to be the vp
and his daughter's got so much poise and
class and you know the way she is so
an ivanka desantis ticket that's an
interesting remember the comments he
just made recent she just made recently
when that when ivanka said
you know if a bar says that then you
know i'll take his word for it so she
also knows how to stand up like you know
i don't know i mean a desantis trump
ticket but an ivanka trump ticket sounds
very interesting to some people and i
just throw a curveball in there saying
a lot of ways to map this out yeah you
could have been working for him on the
apprentice that's a that's a hell of a
move in the boardroom at the last second
uh patrick
pleasure talking tia first off you also
make all the basketball references that
work for me we got to get down here and
shoot some time i've been looking
forward yeah we're going to make that
happen 72 and 10 by the way those 90 uh
that was the 96 bulls right 72 and 10.
72 and 10. not bad
not bad
they called it the greatest basketball
team of all time golden state will
debate it but uh jordan said nobody
would have beaten us i don't think
anyone would have beat those bulls i
mean jordan just he slayed everybody he
just slayed him with six or six in the
finals come on
yeah that's by the way that debate with
lebron
i think it's over with oh i don't i
don't even think it's a debate
it's over with we'll do a separate show
just on old nba i can't i can't do new
mba
all right man you got two minutes to
stick around for one more thing on my
local community page all right fantastic
uh patrickbetdavid links are down below
and we're gonna do a little something on
locals right now if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell